olá a todos
está toda a gente ao vivo em 54
apresentar aqui obrigado a organização é
sempre um prazer voltar ao técnico e
dizem que nunca vemos voltar ao sítio
onde já fomos felizes
não deve haver problema aqui e eu sendo
que o tema da atual que sem limites eu
vou falar de um tema muito ativo e que é
pergunta que é feita sempre é todos os
motoristas em todas as entrevistas
sempre em todo o lado que o morten
limite ea resposta é sempre a mesma
independentemente do humorista que for e
apesar de todos terem o seu próprio
limite muito deus nem sequer gostarem do
trabalho dos outros
a resposta é unânime é é é obviamente o
humor não deve ter limite eu sou da
mesma opinião
mas o humorista é achar que o mundo não
deve ter limite em cada parcial não é a
mesma coisa plantarem um padre se deus
existe mas sem dizer que sim está a
prejudicar o seu ganha-pão né
mas eu por mim acabávamos aqui porque
não há resposta pra mim é tão óbvia que
por agora vou ter que encher chouriços
durante 18 minutos e dar vos a minha
opinião porque eu acho que o humor não
pode não deve e não pode ter limite
e para isso vamos começar com que o
exemplo de um falar sobre o programa de
humor mais ofensivo que já foi feito até
hoje em portugal não sei se alguém quer
arriscar algum nome lucas sorriso elv do
riso usava com doenças sejam mentais ou
psicológicas com lente anos com ciganos
com outras mulheres no geral e tem
alguns bastante longo
só isso já é ofensivo suficiente mas no
entanto expressou durante anos foi líder
de audiência e nós nunca vimos ninguém é
dizer sobre os malucos do riso com
coisas sérias não se brinca com as
nossas avós dizem eram as nossas avós
que estavam os malucos do riso
eu sempre achei esta frase muito
estranha porque eu sempre houve outra
frase que é rir é o melhor remédio e são
as coisas mais sérias doenças mais
graves que precisam mais remédio e
remédio mais forte então nunca me fez
muito sentido isto não é
e ele acha esta fase é um é um
contrassenso que define o que são coisas
sem preço né
um kit fim nisso eu com minha
experiência eu já fiz a porrada de morte
várias vezes e os temas mais sensíveis
que até agora percebi são um golpe para
impedir uma foto antiga do sporting ser
campeão estava no fundo do owa fátima e
religião no geral ea terceira sushi
enrolado até morrer porque os ricos
fanáticos do sushi que se obrigam o
estado surge porque é moda para ter uma
foto bonita com o instagram
toda a gente sabe que essas pessoas
existem portanto parece óbvio que para
definir temas sérios
estranho é porque não tem o seu tema
sério e para definir temas tabus
ok não são uma extensão são temas que
causam sofrimento alguém por causa do
sofrimento principalmente ganhar o
sporting como eu né
quem define o que é o sofrimento dos
outros né eu acho que não faz muito
sentido porque usar com o sofrimento é a
maior fonte resultado é maior fonte é a
fonte de sofrimento é morta e todos nós
vamos morrer não acreditar que dá vida a
esta notícia
tanto usar com a morte de usarmos com os
próprios filhos da nossa própria
desgraça porque evidencia uma doença
terminal não é esse o factor freitas
agora eu acho sinceramente que esta
frase foi dita por mim ontem contava
escrever histórias de sofrimento causado
por uma tragédia é infinitamente maior
ao sofrimento causado por uma piada e já
temos no técnico - por isso uma
expressão matemática infinito mais um é
igual infinito e portanto nunca vai
acontecer uma piada aumentar o
sofrimento de de alguém no meu entender
e e e depois definir o que é a tragédia
é um cara amigo mel brooks esta frase a
tragédia quando o quarto zeloso comédia
quanto cais no esgoto móveis né
isto é uma interiorização do do que
acontece que nós rimos da desgraça dos
outros nem que seja um dia livre não
sermos nós a passar por que ela diga
quando vemos um uma compilação de faixas
na internet um bar de caips cativado com
franquia no chão
nós não estamos a pensar e eqüitativo
colocar em pauta agora só só vai ter
trabalho no call center sem vida chamada
não acontece nós rimos
nós não queremos que aconteça nada mal
né pai mas não fomos nós
o juiz noé e pois é é a mesma coisa com
as doenças porque nós não podemos contar
com algumas doenças e outros podemos não
é o cancro é o tema que é mais sagrado
então as ameaças e nas pessoas morrendo
gripe todos os anos
não se pode fazer piadas quando eles
2015 com espíritos
parece estranho até porque uma pessoa
que morre de gripe a é gripe é mais
gráfico com ela morreu de gripe não é
como é que nós que utilizamos este
sofrimento e achamos que o sofrimento de
uns é melhor do que os outros por mim
sempre foi estranho e as pessoas então
não há temas sagrados
o que há é mau time né do sono que é o
que muita gente diz nos comentários
o turno é uma hipocrisia porque as
pessoas que não estão envolvidas na
tragédia a dizer assim olha hoje sim mal
e rio disto se for possível fazer piada
para a semana já não é móvel está
indignado com isso eu já posso ir à
vontade não é e nunca o ouvi dizer uma
mãe que perdeu um filho é dizer ah não
façam piadas hoje fazendo também é que
já me passou
não é por as pessoas estão realmente
sofrer o tempo não é linear é e
circulares estão sempre no seu
sofrimento e suas 300 urna é só elas
querem viver a própria consciência no
meu entender e aprender a falar do que
piada nunca nunca aumenta o sofrimento
nunca aumenta uma tragédia e nunca se
dirigia para o local foi horrível
promoveram milhões de deus e as piadas
que fizeram sobre aquilo né isso nunca
acontece
e eu acho que essa frase do sul vai
desta frase que do martim naquele que é
mundial e na clínica macchione neto
médico médio a outra série mais tempo eu
percebi isso do ponto de vista do e
quando era pequeno shura isso muitas
coisas e senti me envergonhado e
constrange de hoje rio dakhil e aí
passou o tempo consegui ver como ele
aqui pra mim mas do ponto de vista do
humorista e se não faz sentido nenhum
porque a piada partindo de uma premissa
e essa premissa tem que ter
a carga e essa carga tem que ser
positiva ou negativa tem que ter não
pode ser passado uns anos em que se
gastou no neutro em que já não há
energia na premissa fazer essa piada
ninguém agora morreu outro foi o 14o
céus de que em cinco anos vai ter lugar
já cinco anos que foi o quarto suas em
barcelos não tô ver aquela piada nunca
vai ter piada porque já não têm já não
têm carga e as mais uma vez já que
estamos aqui no técnico prêmios por isso
também uma incursão como ele gosta de
ler mais tempo vamos assumir que o tempo
é igual a zero e que duvida piava
comédia igual a tragédia mais dinheiro
como em outros gêneros amigos
quanto maior o trajeto demora em média
os nossos adversários das unidades nas
ruas mesmo estava indo muito bem e isso
foi mostrado no ponto e portanto eu acho
voltando a outra que tragédia e mais
média igual a tragédia como eu disse mas
como rir é o melhor remédio é piada foi
muito boa
tragédia mas com menor ou igual a
tragédia e resolvendo o sistema de
equações chegamos à conclusão como era o
time mais precisa do sucesso do piso é a
conclusão a que chegamos é e para provar
isso tem um exemplo muito prático que
mostra que a questão da tragédia eo time
não faz é sempre relativo depende de
pessoa para pessoa e os enviou uma
mensagem aos tempos já há um ano ou mais
de uma senhora dizendo porque não fazia
mais piadas com o kangoo porque ela
tinha acabado se da primeira sessão de
quimioterapia e pensava que precisava de
rio do campo e eles a missão era
novamente imenso e não consigo fazer
piadas com cancro porque têm muita
empatia com os doentes porque também
estou sofrer imenso porque tem umas
entradas e não ficar careca e ela riscou
machine no facebook kaká tem vizinhos
com 11 cenas e agradeceu e foi aí que eu
vi experiência o brasileiro poder do
humor é aquela senhora no scala no
momento de maior sofrimento angústia ela
precisava de dizer o cancro que eu crio
vá tudo menos audrey vontade de seguir
ela precisava dizer o campo vem com tudo
contra mim que eu vou dizer que são
consigas e vamos repetir
eu acho que é por isso que serve o humor
e adultos
mas olhar para esta piada que é o meia
acha que eu estou a diminuir o
sofrimento de quem tem cancro quer dizer
como o sofrimento é maior porque estou a
ficar careca e outra forma olha papel
deixa que o próprio torre de cores para
os meus medos e as minhas inseguranças a
pensar do que preocupar com essas
entradas quando há pessoas muito pior
que eu a ficar careca por razões muito
pior e eu acho que é desse fundo que não
acha piada eu acho que nenhum turista
vai para o humorista porque era ofender
e porque ela xinga os outros se quisesse
ter outro painel não vai por um jurista
e eles decidem se é genuína de piada eu
acho que é sempre boa quase sempre e
portanto eu acho que o mais importante é
a única coisa que pode definido
ao limitar o humor em intenção é
intenção de fazer uma piada e porque
piada eu acho que é piauiense nunca pode
discriminar quem discrimina quem diz a
piada que pode estar a discriminar e até
se pode esconder atrás do humor para
discriminar isso também acontece tenho
certeza que nem todos os motoristas são
pessoas fantásticas melhorias carmem e
mas isto é difícil de entender porque é
uma coisa que surge não percebe muitas
vezes é piada ele enfrenta opinião nem
sempre as vezes que se copiam 3g
totalmente diferente e muitas vezes ele
enfrenta realidades são coisas não
aconteceram situações irreais e
fantasiadas e eu gosto de mostrar este
estas três inigualado não acho que sim
é que como a piada do rui sinel de
cordes que eu disse
as mulheres dizem que eu tenho dito
relatório das coisas que elas preparam
contam se viu apenas há três formas da
festa piada
a primeira é achar piada henry s boné ou
chapéu e não vir
são as duas vítimas é precisar e não
achar piada ficar ofendido acha que o
cinema está a promover a violação e que
o próprio villa ms e eu não consigo ver
as pessoas que optam por esta terceira
via não consigo ver
não consigo perceber como é que se parte
do princípio que a intenção do humorista
é pior quando ela é o humorista e
humorista fazer vir e fazer rir acho que
é um é uma coisa nobre e eu acho que
muita gente já não pega mal gosto
o corinthians normalmente disse
o que é um paradoxo porque uma piada
porque fiz uma coisa que faz rir faz rir
não é mau gosto
se for mal gosto deixa de ser uma piada
e passa a ser um comentário no gaúcha
piada nunca pode ser mau gosto na minha
opinião e eu acho que foi muito da
empatia e da empatia que está em com um
comunista eu gosto sempre de gastos
ficam ofendidos e vai romper uma piada
imaginem por voz e melhor amigo é dizer
a mesma piada no jantar da mic e vocês
vão perceber que vão em vez de serem
aquelas 37 pessoas vão ser um dos outros
vão dizer vamos rir fazer é estúpida
estava calado nunca vão ficar ofendido
nem pensar que o vosso amigo tenha pior
das intenções e quer xingar alguém né
vamos pensar que já não é sequer sabem
os valores deu e vamos passar à frente
não vão ficar ofendido eu acho que em
batia tanto do público era comunista é
muito importante também do humorista
para com o público para com as pessoas
de vida eles foram é passar numa rua
vira um célebre e se fizer uma piada
conhecer bill significa que o paraná que
eu sempre quis ganhar aqui e um coral
uma forma de ter sido escolhida que o
como piada
eu acho que é muito legal passar na rua
e nem sequer pararam sem abrigo
acho que minha opinião e portanto eu
acho que depois da empatia está fora do
sítio histórico
mas para além da intenção da empatia
temos uma coisa é o contexto eo contas
pode nos atos uma coisa dentro de um
contexto turístico tem uma cara uma
coisa de tudo o que acontece tem outra
tem outra cara e um exemplo fácil este
do tranco em que usou qualquer porta
eficiente e todos nós que foi horrível
mas vimos aqui tudo é possível
a unidade e o que é certo é que nós já
fizemos com o sumiço é verdão
qual é a diferença primeiro não somos
candidatos a presidente dos estados
unidos não estamos a dizer perante
milhões de pessoas eo nosso objetivo não
era assim que ele era um centro de
tecnologia centro na sala para
encaminhar nosso objetivo era apenas e
só fazer uma piada para ou não com a
semp água é que não há que a intenção
foi denegrir a imagem de viabilizar um
jornalista com base na deficiência
física deu o rímel imenso quando foi
copiada por ridículo da situação não foi
como um escape nem é possível
atrasado então isso junto me olhou e
ganhou um cheque teve que voltar atrás
aí é que o quanto essa empatia ea
intenção é prova eu que limita a
liberdade de expressão liberdade de
expressão existe exatamente para nós
podermos é ofender os outros você chama
as coisas não ofendi ninguém não
precisam estar na lei da liberdade são
lembrados pressão existe para que possam
dizer coisas que incomodam os outros ea
liberdade expressão em si também já
estão já tem limite por exemplo é
possível ser racista e possivelmente se
assumir como racista mas é proibido
plantar vai fazer propaganda e propagar
o racismo incentivar o ódio ao crime
é uma diferença e muito grande né e
portanto eu acho que o mortal na mesma
coisa da liberdade de expressão é o de
graduação humor é uma forma de expressão
portanto só pode ser limitado pelas
mesmas lojas que ruíram todas as outras
formas de disposição porque senão caímos
nisto a esse tema ofendido mas não vou
ficar feliz quando está ofendido como é
que a gente agora resolve isso não na
lapa resolver tanto para esperam o corpo
que temos opiniões diferentes que não
têm sensibilidade de frente que não tem
um em seu limite diferente nos esse
limite é pessoal e intransmissível não
pode ser o limite de uns é impor o o
limita aos outros e e eu digo sempre que
o fez e eu digo nenhum lugar que nunca e
ofensa nunca levava eu fui sempre tomava
uma escolha do setor ofender só não só
vamos chamar nomes no trânsito
eu escolhi ficar ofendido com o quilo ou
não eu se eu quiser ofender
eu por si só querer ofender não consegue
aprender a não ser que o cara e eu acho
que provei isto eu costumo dizer que tem
crescido a minha opinião que 99 900
pessoas são burras
o que acontece é uma tentativa
deliberada de ofender 99 gol 900 pessoas
ninguém ficou ferido toda a gente pensa
que a 0 1%
isto é prova que o mesmo entendendo a
ofender outras pessoas
ninguém ficou ferido porque não tomam
para si essa ofensa e não não tem nada
contra eu acho que é menos humoristas
choram se demais com isto ficam feridas
não fui a tempo nós gostamos que haja
pessoas afinal nós temos sete pessoas
e eu defender o direito de as pessoas se
ofenderem o que quiserem de morrer em
volta com base nessa ofensa que
acostumaram se senhor tomou a ponta e eu
acho que o politicamente correto em
portanto politicamente correto fez com
que nós convivemos melhor na sociedade
com os outros que fosse mais e melhor
para toda a gente à minha namorada me
perguntasse estar mais gorda é
politicamente correto dizer que não
porque senão vai piorar a vida dela e
mim ainda mais né do politicamente
correto com um propósito eu acho que as
pessoas se devem voltar e lutar e
ofender se e tentar mudar as coisas
sobre o carro só acho mal agora não
percebo que haja mais comentário de
dólares numa página do humorista do que
na página do pnr né os cats do gás da
alfama do jato durante dizia um
muçulmano e um bicho que soltava e
reinventar e no contexto turístico é uma
sátira é uma sátira que desconstrói esse
conceito que ajuda a ultrapassar esse
preconceito na boca do gato do pnr é só
estupidez ódio e discriminação e é aí
que está o alvo dos ofendidos do
politicamente correto que hoje devemos
numa altura em que estão por todo o lado
porque passamos não só usava uma pizza
do facebook ep do facebook que acha que
tentava nos faz na casa dos pais né vai
frustrar sexualmente e achei legal estou
vendo por portar ou se o marcos o carga
né e não sabes que discutir não sabem
fazer uma escolha simples que estão no
fim não é e há duas horas enquanto fazem
ao tempo por nando revólver enquanto
descansavam que envolve estou vendo e
tem duas opções quer continuar os call
ou investir vestir de energia ene
substrato ofendido que a província tem
um wiki no meu comentário me senti
melhor com minha vida de merda porque
isso eu acho que é isso que está nos
gémeos e o engraçado é que foram todos
charlie naquela semana em que foi moda
né
naquela semana em que foi moda por foto
do perfil foram todos muito chorão e sem
perceberem que esta atitude censurar os
outros decrescentes horário que os
outros falam em mesma atitude que está
nos genes da tragédia do dojo charme né
porque é que os turistas que mataram até
os sete turistas é premissa deus era
estou vendo eu quero falar vou te matar
e por omissão destas pessoas que se
querem censurar os outros é exatamente o
mesmo
a diferença é que os outros acreditam
mesmo com o celta com 72 virgens e e se
torna cada vez mais não acredito nisso
porque se acreditassem eu garanto que
muitas vezes os caras fazem o mesmo e
ouvir não estou a comparar o e gravidade
das ações um comportamento diferente mas
o time legendas no pensamento que
origina isso eu acho que o mesmo é eu
não gosto que estás a dizer esta via
fica lá e isso pra mim é perigoso e é
não só é perigoso como não é preciso
eu acho que todos os motoristas fazem
todos os ministros têm um mecanismo de
autocensura em contínuas que é virar
piada e ofensa por nós sabemos que tudo
é potencialmente ofensiva se o sushi e
não é tudo é ser mal seus a um
colecionador de selos não sei onde vai
dizer à morte na china estuda ofendendo
nós queremos e tem muito mais piada do
que ofende e nós já fazemos isto e vocês
é ok mas há pessoas que só querem
ofender as pessoas estão preocupadas em
defender e explicar a mas este nunca
chegou a minha porque o público o
público faça isto que o ricky gervais
diz que nara única forma válida de
censura eu tenho direito não houve
excessos sem humorista eo número de
vezes fazer rir só choca
elas vão deixar escrito e que o muricy
vai deixar de o ser porque nunca foi
nunca fez ninguém não é humorista né é
um gás principal hermes em palco e
portanto eu acho que isso é importante
é importante perceber que podemos ficar
o felipe podemos discutir os limites do
humor podemos batê-los podemos mostrar
insatisfação mas não podemos censurar ei
que as coisas começam a ficar perigosas
porque essas pessoas que gostam de
censurar motoristas
epá funk no mural vestígios dos videntes
canção tão simpáticos vão parar em sua
visita à coréia do norte para a turquia
onde os jornalistas os juristas os blogs
são censurados um preço mortos muitas
vezes é pai não parece quase viva melhor
e nunca fui lá é um facto mas eu acho
que o único sítio usando o humor tem um
limite ao chip ou não liberdade em si
também tem um limite
e para terminar vou mostrar que o cheiro
de um dos netos do do irmã do problema
que é o humor de perdição foi em 1988 e
que foi censurado e já tinha passado 25
de abril mas mesmo assim foi foi
censurado foi censurado no ano que não
tem programa é má e foi cortado
tem havido muitas queixas que via uma
rábula quer entrevistas históricas que
ofendia morre ea honra de personalidades
históricas e que censurar os últimos
dois programas foram também censurado só
passaram nem ter anos depois e os x
server bousquet começasse vos mostrar e
eu acho que tem diz muito
é a segunda santa cruz e santa paciência
todos nós aqui temos que ter para fazer
humor em portugal num bom fazer agora é
portugal estar mas eu estou convencido
que daqui há duas gerações
este painel científico não foi não foi
entregue apenas em evitar de souza não
está errado
não foi eu acho que faz parte dessa
segunda geração duas gerações as
esquerdas de pessoas que tentam fazer
várias outras de que eu vejo é que hoje
em dia é demasiada gente com linhas né
não deixa os outros pensar em sair que
não gosta então direito deus nos
tentaram ofenderam o censurar os outros
aqui é para quem não pode ser e eu acho
que a única resposta é única é forma de
se combater isso é é não ter medo de
ofender sabe que isso faz parte e não
pedir desculpa porque desculpa pedras
quando se tem culpa se a pessoa não há
intenção não é ofender não têm conta nos
preocupa e hoje podem sempre com esta
frase de jorge carone pra mim o melhor
humorista de sempre e desafogue jogo
portanto é a vossa vida e não está em
lugar disso e portanto muito obrigado a
vocês por terem vindo aqui querem ouvir
e é isso
[Aplausos]